Linear function - example 1
In my last video, we tried to calculate
Wall surface area of ​​this strange building
We have the accumulated f(xy) of xy to indicate the ceiling area.
f(xy) is equal to x plus the square of y
Then the ground of the building, or the outline of the wall
Then there is an arc with a radius of 2
Plus part of the y-axis, then left
Including a part of the x-axis, this is our building
In the previous video
We calculated the surface area of ​​the first wall
In fact, our real purpose should be
Calculate this linear integral from the straight line segment to the curve
This is a closed line integral along the constant c
Set to the equation f for xy
We often multiply the integrand f(xy) by the length of the curve (in ds)
We try to represent it in the most abstract way.
The easiest way we learned from the previous video
Is to break the whole problem into multiple segments
Multiple curves, or multiple different problems to solve
Imagine this whole wall outline
All line segments, curve segments, we call it c
As you can see from the previous video, this is c1
This paragraph, I made a mark, it is c2
Now I mean this is c3
Let's redefine it, or break it down
Decompose the entire closed linear integral into three independent linear integrals
The entire line integral is equal to
Linear integral of c1 segment plus c2
Plus, you may have guessed, haha, c3 points
In the previous video
We figured out the first part
The entire curved wall here
The surface area of ​​the wall is 4+2
Now we need to calculate the remaining two parts
Ok, let's start calculating c2
If you want to calculate it
Also write a parameter for x and y
And this will be different from the parameters of c1
We are no longer focused on this arc.
We are on the y-axis
As long as it is on the y-axis
The x coefficient is always 0
These are my parameters, x=0
When we are on the y-axis, x is always equal to 0.
Next is the y coefficient, we can first set y equal to 2
Or, we can say that y is equal to 2 minus t
t is greater than or equal to 0, less than or equal to 2
This is the correct parameter
When t is equal to 0, at this point
But when t increases to t equals 2
Point t will move down the y axis to point t=2
here
This is our correct parameter
Let's analyze this line c2
We can also try to calculate the derivative
What is the derivative of x=0?
Let me write, what is the dt point dx
Directly speaking
The derivative of 0 is 0
The dy of dt is the derivative of this formula
That is -1, right?
2 minus the derivative of t, is negative 1
Then let's analyze it again.
This line here
That is, linear integral c2
I will put c2 here first, we can still say
From t equals 0 to t equals 2, then f(xy)
f(xy) is this stuff, x plus y squared
Then multiply by ds
everybody knows
Ds can also be expressed as the dt of the dt minus the dt of the dt under the root number
That is, the square of 0 under the root number is reduced by 1, that is, plus 1
Multiply the whole dt
Very clear and beautiful
Here is 0 plus 1, plus the root number, the whole is 1
Then what is x?
x, if we write according to the previous parameters
x will always be equal to 0, and the square of y will be equal to
2 minus t the square of the whole
So this will be 2 minus t the square of the whole
Finally, let’s simplify this whole crazy formula.
From t equals 0 to t equals 2, the x value will disappear from the argument
x is 0, no matter what t is equal to
We have the square of y, y is equal to 2 minus t
So 2 minus t the square of the whole
Finally, there is a lonely dt
This process is straightforward
I think it would be easier to find the anti-derivatives.
You can directly mentally calculate
But what I like is
Multiply this binomial
So this line integral is equal to
From t equals 0 to t equals 2, 4 minus 4t plus squared t
Multiply dt
Still very directly
The whole is 4t minus 2t square
4t minus 2t, right?
2 times negative 2
Get negative 4t, then add a third of the cube, right?
Simple anti-derivatives of these things
What we need is from 0 to 2
Ok, let's make t equal to 2
4 by 2 is 8, let me change a color
4 times 2 is 8, minus 2 times 2 squares, which is 8, then added
1/3 by 2 cube
So it is 1/3 by 8
After offsetting
The remaining 8 minus 8, the last is 8/3
The final result is eight-eighth
Must have another case where t is equal to 0
The whole is equal to 0
4 times 0, 2 times 0, the whole is 0
Then subtract 0
Hey, we found the surface area of ​​the second wall.
This is finally equal to 8/3
Now, only the last wall is left.
Then add them all together
Get the last wall
I will list another parameter.
I want you to see that picture.
Ok, maybe I can copy another side.
edit
Haha, this is our picture.
Start our last wall now
This wall can be represented
Expressed as c3
Change color
This is c, we have to calculate c3 f(xy) by ds
That is... I will write the parameters again.
Along this arc, if we assume x is equal to t
t is greater than or equal to 0
Less than or equal to 2, we will stay on the x-axis
So the y value is equal to 0
a direct parameter
This is equal to f(xy) from t equals 0 to t equals 2
That is...
I use xy directly
x plus y, multiply by ds
Ok, what is dx? Well, let me write down ds
Multiply ds
This is our theme
Now we know ds
Ds is equal to the square of the dx of the dt under the root number
Plus dt points the square of the dy overall, multiply dt
We have already proven it in the first video.
Or we have probably understood why
Will be like this
Then what is the derivative of x under the influence of t
Is 1, this is equal to 1
The square of 1 is the same as 1
The derivative of y is still 0
0, 1 plus 0 equals 1, root number 1 or 1
This thing is dt
Ds will be equal to dt
So this is the value of dt
Then, because x is equal to t
y is equal to 0
So ignore the existence of y
This is a super invincible simple line score
After simplification, by t equal to 0 to equal to 2 times dt
Anti-derivative t
Equal to 1/2t square, t has two values
When t is equal to 2
The square of 2 is 4, multiplied by one-half is equal to 2, and then reduced by 0.
Because 1/2 times 0 square, it is 0
In this way, we have the third wall, equal to 2
Very direct
So that area is 2
Ok, what to answer is the value of this linear integral.
f(xy)
We will add these numbers together
4 plus 2 plus 8/3 plus 2
Addition and subtraction calculation
Finally plus 2 factions
End! !
It’s finally over! !
Now we can use vector functions
To solve the linear integral.
Thank you! Translated by MikeHe mikehe0410@gmail.com